[Music]
this woman's husband was an inmate at
gotega prison in burundi we've hidden
her face and changed her voice for her
safety
when it caught fire two months ago she
was worried she says she's been to the
prison to try and find out if he
survived but she's not been able to see
him since the guards told her nothing
and sent her away she says another
inmate told her her husband was among
those who burned to death
we don't know how they were buried our
children keep asking me where their
father is i tell them that he died one
of them asked me will you take us to see
his grave when he hears someone calling
me he is asking if it is his father
because he didn't see his funeral or his
body
she's one of many relatives of inmates
who haven't had any official answers
the nearly 100 year old prison was
overcrowded holding three times as many
inmates as it was built for
survivors say one block was badly burned
and the guards refused to unlock the
doors
burundi's vice president visited the
following day he said an electrical
fault started it the government has
since said a report is being prepared
and that 46 inmates died
we spoke to an inmate who says that's
not true
from my sale i could see the bodies
being removed in the morning they
pitched tents and in each tent they
packed 15 to 20 bodies and we counted
there were 20 tens so it's about 300 or
400 a shocking number of dead people the
government declined to comment when we
asked rights groups say the government's
trying to cover up a disaster for which
it's responsible and that it should
investigate and publish the list of
names of those who died
when you have a fire such as this with
with potentially massive death counts
that that goes well beyond uh the
official number uh that's an
embarrassment it it it reflects the
reality which is that um there is a
there is a systemic issue with
incarceration in burundi
this man says he wants to know what
happened to his brother who was an
inmate but he fears being jailed or
killed himself
we cannot continue asking questions for
the sake of our safety asking again is
like a criminal offence we have to keep
quiet
he's from one of dozens maybe hundreds
of bereaved families seeking closure but
are too scared to even ask what happened
to their loved ones malcolm webb al
jazeera